[Music]
leaders of the Brooks Alliance of five
nations have invited another six
countries to join they are Argentina
Egypt Ethiopia Iran Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates the annual Brook
Summit is being held in Johannesburg the
leaders of Brazil India China and South
Africa are there while Russia's
President is on video link for Moscow
the South African president made the
expansion announcement
we have decided to invite
the Argentine Republic
the Arab Republic of Egypt
the federal Democratic Republic of
Ethiopia
the Islamic Republic run
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
and the United Arab Emirates
to become full members of brics
the membership will take effect from the
first of January 2024.
is joining us live from Johannesburg
Brook's group attracting a level of
Interest rarely seen since its founding
in 2014 for me the dozens of countries
expressed their interest in joining but
only six have been accepted for now
it's likely Elizabeth that the criteria
was pretty tight in terms of who they
might admit there's been a lot of debate
a debate amongst these brics members
around who should be admitted when that
should be done and uh looking at who
they've included uh in this admission we
see also increased representation from
African countries Ethiopia and Egypt and
South Africa has been squarely behind
that wanting African countries the
global South to have a bigger place uh
within this grouping but to give us
greater insight into what might have
informed this decision we're speaking to
Michael barseq in a global Affairs
analyst now Michael what is likely
behind the admission of these six new
members what is it that would have taken
them into the brics grouping sure well
it looks like China was very very keen
to expand bricks in fact the Chinese
foreign minister spoke foreign Ministry
spokesperson said it's going to breed
new Vitality into the block for sure it
will but the choice is very interesting
so we have Argentina somewhere more
representation from South America Egypt
Ethiopia African continent Ethiopia was
I think a little bit unexpected uh Iran
I have a suspicion there might have been
some Russian maneuvering behind that
they're close allies and then Saudi
Arabia and UAE that that
signals to me more cash and fusion into
the Development Bank uh misting there
was Indonesia and Mexico we were
expecting them to come in as well we've
repeatedly heard from the existing
leadership of brics that this is about
Unity it's about the global South
greater representation but this comes
amidst heightening Global tensions while
bricks may be forming a more solid block
globally are there concerns around
greater fragmentation oh absolutely a
couple of quick things one is we're
seeing the deterioration of this
multilateral for G7 G20 uh APAC even
watered down Communicator none
whatsoever at least here they managed to
come up with a quite a big announcement
about the expansion but when you see
countries like Iran coming in and also
you listen to the rhetoric coming out of
the conference for example from people
like Mr Lula Brazil a lot of talk here
about not using the US dollar anymore uh
leveling the playing field for African
countries you see quite the
fragmentation I think just quickly I
think it's got to the point where good
luck to America trying to uh went back
to the Loyalty of some of these African
countries I think a lot of them are
shifting more towards this direction
just very quickly do these
could have enough
for bricks
think so when you look at China India
especially Russia now Iran uh Brazil
Lula from Brazil again he's very
contrarian and saying what he wants to
see very very strong on climate good
luck convincing the Russians and the
Chinese and in fact India to adhere to
those High climate standards Michael
thanks very much for your time though
speaking to Michael boss secure Global
Affairs analyst we do know that it's
taken months of discussion to get to
this point but ultimately the existing
members of brics want to forge ahead
with this multi-polar world they say a
more Equitable world and essentially
realigning a geopolitics I'm going to
thank you for that that is fine of the
middle live in Johannesburg